- [Violet] Sustainability is key.
It's not meant to be a privilege.
It's more than selling your
products in the market.
- [Andy] It's about being
good stewards of the planet
that we live on and
protecting the resources
that are out there.
- [Sydney] We can't just have a few people
working on it and then other people saying,
"Okay, they're working
on it, we don't have to."
Everyone needs to work together.
- Whether you're just recycling at home,
or watching how much water you're using,
lots of little things can
add up to a big change.
- Clean drinking water is quite important.
Western Kenya is a very
rich area in times of rain,
but unfortunately most of
this rain goes into rivers
that are not protected.
People wash their clothes
in the same water.
They will take their animals to drink
water from those same rivers.
By the time the people
at the bottom of the hill
get access to that water,
it's quite contaminated.
- At Method, water's one
of the main ingredients
in our product, so we
look to develop techniques
that can offset the usage.
In the beginning we set a goal,
for a lead platinum certification,
to be an ecologically advanced factory.
To reduce our carbon footprint,
we've got the greenhouse on the roof.
We look at sustainability from
how can we have our business
and really minimize its
impact on the environment
but also even be restorative
to the environment.
- Styrofoam, actually,
when it gets to landfills,
it takes a long time to decompose.
The Eco-Bin was a robotics
team project at first.
We decided to go talk to the
people at Friendship Village.
They told us that styrofoam was one of
their biggest problems.
And so, we invented a way
to make non-toxic glue.
We pour our solution of
delaminate and other chemicals
onto it and we reduced
it to 1/20th of its size.
- [Violet] It's very
easy to work with kids,
because they are good agents of change.
They will go back home and
teach their own parents.
LifeStraw works through ultra-filtration.
It holds back all the microorganisms,
and the clean water is sieved out.
I love my job because it answers for me
the question, "Why?"
Seeing their faces when they
see the difference in the water
is an honor for me.
- [Andy] I've got a lot
of pride for being here.
I started when there was
nothing on this site.
We chose to be part of the local community
and see how Method's investment
could positively impact the
community that we reside in.
- As kids it was always "Later on in life
"we could have a big future."
It turns out that you can
accomplish big things now,
it doesn't have to be later on.
- [Andy] It's rewarding.
You're not just here to make soap.
This is the only planet that we have
so it's important for
us to take care of that
and have it there for future generations.